total war warhammer 3 might have the
best battles we've seen so far
in this long beloved franchise alongside
the new factions unit story and
everything else that comes with new
entries to the series there are also
massive new narrative style survival
battles which is what i got hands on
with recently these survival battles
exist
as big narrative landmarks through the
campaigns of total war warhammer 3.
so whether you're playing as kislev cafe
or one of the forces of chaos
you'll be taken to these cursed fields
as part of the main questline they're
designed to feel like big
important and memorable battles and from
what i've played
they seem to be really nailing it
warriors of kislev
we have travelled far and
but at last we have arrived in corn's
bloody realm
before us stands the bra citadel
where the blood god's gatekeeper stands
guard
we must call out the fiend and slay him
they died
the idea behind them is that your
faction is invading the realms of the
chaos gods
and in the gameplay you can see right
now i'm playing as kislev under the
command of the tsarina catarin
against the hordes of corn the god of
blood and skulls
which will go some way to explaining the
decor choices in this crimson neck of
the woods
while we are yet to see them there will
be other survival battles that take
place in the other three realms as well
so expect to see gross pus and boils for
nurgle tentacles and
excess for slaanesh and physics i don't
know
clocks anyway these long wars of
attrition start with you bringing in a
force into the realm of chaos
and advancing as you take strategic
objectives one at a time
until finally a greater demon approaches
for the final showdown
cons gatekeeper shows himself at last
warriors of kislev prepare for the fight
of your lives
now once you take one of these
objectives the battle switches from you
assaulting points
to putting up a desperate defense to
assist you in holding on to your new
fielded prize
with each point taken you as the player
are able to summon more units
build strong defenses heal and resupply
or buff your existing forces
all paid for with a currency called
supply which is earned by taking victory
points and defeating demons and
nerdwells this is where i feel the
battles
really shine through and present
themselves as a fresh new way to wage
war within the total war franchise
because you don't have enough supply to
do everything you want you really have
to stay on your feet with the strategies
you employ
when it comes to defending your strong
point or lean into the play style you
feel most comfortable with
all of this in order to give yourself
every advantage possible
as you face off some truly overwhelming
odds
some of the building options available
to your defensive force include among
others
a selection of towers flinging arrows or
bolts of magic
stall walls to cut off approaches firing
platforms to allow your range units to
fire down death
traps to slow and wound the enemy and
idols that buff allied forces that stay
within their field
this is a great new option if you're
someone like me who leans into a
defensive play style
making the most of choke points
strengthening your position favoring
units with high defense
and using your cossa or strategy gun and
axe units to take down enemies on their
approach
with your walls and towers you can
create your very own bottlenecks and
force the enemy to fight where you want
them now they can take down these
defenses but if they bunch up and start
hacking away at your walls
well thankfully your general and ice
mage have some pretty
devastating area of effect spells to
have those berserkers shattering
alternatively you can spend your
resources on kitting out your units with
higher tier weapons and armor
to make your smaller fighting force
really pack a punch
this sort of tower defense gameplay adds
a new wrinkle to battles
and being able to use the terrain to
your advantage and turn enemy points
into fortifications of your own really
is important when it comes to balancing
the attack and defense dynamic of the
survival battles
but it is also important to bear the
fight ahead in mind
when you sell fortifications you get a
few resources back and allow you to
shift focus to the skirmishes ahead of
you
these battles are taking place behind
enemy lines and
in unfamiliar territory that means you
can expect to have demons
constantly spawning behind you and
taking the fight to your flanks
usually this will result in you having
to split your force and fight on
multiple fronts
testing the micromanaging abilities of
any commander because as this fight
progresses
and you get access to bigger and better
units like the elemental bear and grom
cannons so too will the demons of corn
try their best to throw
their considerable weight around meaning
that by the end of these battles you're
likely beset on all fronts
scrambling together what little
resources you have to heal repair and
reinforce exhausted forces
all while greater demons skull crushers
and angry lads with names like skarg
fleshmaul try to turn your femurs into
toothpicks
this crescendo of battle you work
towards really feels like a worthwhile
payoff
to the drawn out invasions that will
mostly last players at least
40 minutes
he is
dash
total war has always created some really
exciting climactic experiences to their
quest battles
but the ebb and flow of these survival
battles alongside the wealth of
customizable options
really works in creating something new
for the series
the new battle setting of the brass
citadel as well as some of the awesome
new units of kislev and corn were really
exciting to get my hands on
and honestly as a huge total war and
warhammer fan i can't wait to play more
of this final installment of the series
but personally it was the survival
battles themselves that really stood out
to me
whether you're fighting through them
solo in your campaign or bringing in
your friends as allies and playing them
co-op online
i hope other total war fans out there
are as excited for the survival battles
as i am if you enjoyed this video be
sure to like it tell me your thoughts of
these battles in the comments section
down below i'll be in the comments
section as soon as this video goes live
to answer as many questions as i can
and for more of your virtual warhammer
fix be sure to subscribe
to gamespot my brave kiss levites
we stand triumphant but corn is not the
only dark god with a realm in this
accursed place
the battle is won but the war goes on
come we must continue our search
for what is lost
you